you have a whole bunch of blocks but in
order for me to illustrate what's going
on and for it to be sort of a scale
that's reasonable I went down to the
woodwork shop so that I could get
something a little larger okay something
I can move around them more easily so
what I have done them on the board is
similar to what you have done with the
blocks edit your books and on your
laptops okay so I have a couple of
isosceles triangles here or I almost
dude I need to construct from these
equal sides I need to construct that
third side don't I okay so let's just do
it for this one here okay so I have my
triangle there right now hopefully as
you went through it as you measured okay
you would have had some legs up here you
know I think I had something like this
five five and then this would be three
okay and then you went and you did some
angles okay so here's what I measured
while you were working I measured the
one that I had and this is what I got I
have my 71 degrees 35 degrees and 71
that's what I measured now before we
make any conclusions through this let's
just look at it notice a few things okay
number one add up these ankles if you
add up these ankles look at the weepy
now what do you get
what do you get yeah Brendon okay now
you're expecting to get a hundred eighty
aren't you we have ones that the angle
sum of a triangle is 180 degrees but if
you have a look at my numbers that's
just a 1 in time 71 plus 35 is a hundred
and electric six plus 71 is
a hundred and seventy seven question
mark okay now
legit question this is not the main
point I'm making but I heard you arrived
at something similar yeah W uh I don't
know I don't have 180 okay now question
and I can think of at least two answers
to this you don't to raise their hand
this is just why don't I have a hundred
eighty degrees okay first attempt yeah
okay excellent so I'm gonna peach one of
these so but you never for a second I'll
come back to using you've got this
instrument here right and well it's not
perfect and you can only measure so well
like what my eyesight is terrible so
here between one degree I'm not sure if
it's twenty thirty five point one or
thirty five point two cartel so I'm
early so accurate we have what we call
key limits of accuracy okay there's the
first suggestion somebody give me
another one exactly right sir number one
the instrument I'm using has a limit but
number two I quit constructed something
and it's not perfect do you remember we
were talking about our Euclid a few
lessons ago right and here's
introduction to geometry he knew that
this was a perfect but he imagined a
world where it was and in that world
every triangle adds up to exactly 180
degrees you can measure everything
perfectly it's not the world we live in
that doesn't mean it's not real okay all
right now let's move on here's what I'm
interested in looking at okay yeah
yes come on said yep yep again again I
put that on the limits about us yet
because we just choose these okay so now
here's the thing that's interesting okay
how about looking travels what do you
notice about them what do you know
we start with two equal sides right that
was how we constructed this way what did
we end up with yes okay all right so you
might be GG I'll play I'm gonna change
this in seconds what I can see you know
is that these areas here in these
quarters right they're always equal
right we started with equal sides and
what you end up with without a choice is
you end up with equal angles if they're
not equal that's down to just limits of
accuracy and when you're measuring right
not only are they equal but can you see
they're always down here it's never this
one up here except by coincidence if you
you know by quinces make it be
collateral triangle cuz that they're all
equal it's always these guys it's always
been a goes market it's this is really
really important it's always the angles
that are opposite the key cool science
that's so important how to say it again
and in fact I've not actually write down
okay every time you have a triangle with
equal sides of it they're equal angles
and the equal angles up opposite equal
sides I'll write that down as well so
should you yes okay so looking at their
position okay so let me write that down
equal angles equal angles are opposites
equal sides and you have to be right
let's have a look at this Sun this
triangle over here okay it's a bit
smaller but I could do the same thing
okay and I mark out my third side the
one that's not equal to the other two
right
even without measuring you can see
there's a smaller angle over here right
and then there's these two buyers who
clearly are the same size and
measurement will confirm that okay it's
not only when there's one small one and
two bigger ones right let's let's just
click this triangle put it over there if
I now take the same science right and I
make the angle between them really
really large so think of angles now what
kind of triangle is this with regard to
angles
it's a obtuse triangle very good because
that's that angles huge right now when I
make this third side that angle up there
is obtuse like you said it's huge you
have these two smaller angles but again
go ahead and measure and you actually
did you will find that they are equal to
each other okay equal angles are
opposite equal science you will see this
root of another way as well I so you can
put this underneath this right would
have been making my stops of these
triangles right so sometimes this gets
cold the reason is that base in groups
in isosceles triangles cuz that's that's
what we're working with base tables in
isosceles triangles are equal it's the
same idea I prefer the first way of
saying it because it's a bit faster and
also this web base right if I say Oh
where's the base of a pyramid you would
say it's at the it's at the bottom right
even you know like to say something as
basic as you know low level okay and
sure enough sometimes these equal angles
are at the bottom right there at the
bottom but then you
to be at the bottom they could be over
here on the side or if you want you can
draw you can draw the triangle upside
down like this
and then you all base angles on at the
top of the triangle I think that's a bit
funny okay
so it's fine you will sometimes see it
written that way and it's totally
correct I like this one though it's a
bit quicker and it's more helpful okay